[Musique]
le gouvernement du québec s'apprête à
augmenter le taux de la redevance sur
l'eau qui est exigée aux industries ou
aux industries qui en font une grande
consommation l'an dernier à moins de 3
millions de dollars qui ont été versés
pour des prélèvements d'eau de 811
milliards de litres à faire le point
avec rebecca pétrin et les directrice
générale chez au secours bonsoir madame
d'être un bon soir alors comment on peut
qualifier le régime la redevance qui est
en place les tarifs en vigueur en ce
moment au québec non ce moment on n'est
clairement plus faible que les autres
provinces du canada et même des autres
pays et surtout en union européenne où
les tarifs sont très élevés et
nonobstant les tarifs qui est payé par
les compagnies qui prélève de l'eau il y
aussi la quantité d'eau qui est prélevé
quotidiennement qui est gratuite donc au
québec chaque personne qui prélève de
l'oat droit 75002 gratuit avant de
commencer à payer une redevance
d'ailleurs quand on parle de redevances
vous dites on est pas mal plus bas
qu'ailleurs on peut voir un tableau où
on se compare avec l'ontario par exemple
bon ça coûte à peu près 70 dollars pour
un million de litres pour les
entreprises qui sont dans l'extraction
par exemple embouteillages ou québec
pour la fabrication c'est de dollars 50
mais voyez l'ontario le sait facilement
7 8 fois plus élevés à tout le moins
pour l'extraction est ce qu'on devrait
s'inspirer de ce qui se fait dans la
province voisine ou encore de ce qui se
fait en europe oui parfaitement on
devrait en inspirer aux mêmes qu'on
devrait aller au delà de ça donc ce
tarif là qui ont été imposées par
l'ontario date déjà de 2020 donc ils ont
déjà deux ans vu l'inflation qu'on a eu
dans les dernières années on pourrait
même revoir ça à la hausse on verra ce
que le gouvernement nous proposera par
le soudan son projet de loi oui bon en
fait on se dit il ya beaucoup d'eau au
québec on a d'importantes réserves d'eau
douce est une richesse d'ailleurs est ce
que est ce que ça justifie le fait qu'on
paie moins cher ici ou au contraire
il faut resserrer la réglementation
même si au québec on a beaucoup d'hommes
dont trois pour cent des ressources
mondiales
c'est pas vrai qu'on doit le laisser se
gaspiller malheureusement on a beaucoup
d'autres qui dans le nord du territoire
et la population qui se situe dans le
sud on peut décemment facilement accès
l'autre important de la voilà où on en a
besoin et puis on peut voir dans les
dernières dans les derniers étés eu de
plus en plus des épisodes de stress
hydrique dans différentes municipalités
différentes régions donc il faut faire
attention à la façon qu'on utilise l'eau
et à l'endroit on utilise est ce qu'on
devrait bon la façon dont ça fonctionne
avec la tarification actuelle c'est
modulée en fonction de l'utilisation
qu'on en fait quels types d'industries
est-ce qu'on doit continuer de faire ça
ou ça doit être un tarif élevé pour tout
le monde et je vais aller jusqu'à cesser
la distribution d'eau gratuite vous
parliez de 75 litres par jour est ce que
tout ça doit doit être mis de côté tout
ce doit être un briquet dans des grandes
orientations qui doivent être partagé à
l'ensemble de la province donc ce qui
reporte premièrement c'est de voir l'eau
on veut l'utiliser à quoi c'est quoi nos
priorités provinciale c'est
l'agriculture locale pour nous c'est
quelque chose qui est important faut
qu'on puisse les prévoit donc la
redevance pourrait également réfléchir
et nos priorités en tant que québécois
donc une entreprise qu'on voudrait un
moins favorisés plus que l'agriculture
pourrait devoir payer un tarif plus
élevé qu'un autre donc on pourrait
moduler la redevance comme ça et on
pourrait également moduler les quantités
d'eau gratuite par jour en fonction des
priorités qu'on se voit décerner les
différents secteurs industriels qui sont
justement les industriels les plus
gourmands en eau en ce moment les plus
gourmands la palme d'or revient aux
papetières donc tout l'industrie
papetière pouvoir casser un chef ou 6 kg
et pour l'ensemble de l'industrie donc
pas nécessairement par entreprise les
deuxièmes sont les embouteilleurs donc
tout ce qui est microbrasserie brasserie
et boissons sucrées et eau ainsi que les
troisièmes on est dans le domaine des
produits chimiques engrais et autres
mais qui demande énormément d'eau et
dans le top 5 qui vient en tous cas l
industrie minière est ce que ces
entreprises la quantité d'eau qu'elle
prélève est-ce que c'est raisonnable si
on se compare au bassin
dolla qu'on a dont on a à disposition ou
est-ce qu'on n'impose un stress sur le
système hydrique du québec c'est un
point très sensible que vous mentionnez
parce que jusqu'à présent on n'a
toujours pas les quantités qui sont
prélevés par comme par industrie donc
nous c'est une demande qu'on a fait il y
à déjà quatre ans donc en 2018 et on
s'est vu refuser cette information là
tout secret commercial donc en mars
dernier on est parti devant la cour du
québec pour un appel ils nous ont
toujours refusé cet axe-là donc la
semaine dernière par contre à
l'assemblée nationale une motion qui a
été déposé pour une réforme
réglementaire pour rendre accessibles
ces données là et cette motion est
acceptée par l'ensemble des partis donc
peut-être qu'on pourrait inclure cette
réforme là dans le prochain projet de
loi des redevances ce sens ça semble un
peu politique aussi ce dossier là du
moins on s'opposait au gouvernement a
relevé la redevance sur l'eau il ya
quelques mois a même encore et là
changement de cap à la toute fin de la
période
la session parlementaire pourquoi on
change d'idée comme ça votre avis
probablement que les différents stress
hydrique on vit depuis quelques étés
déjà doivent préoccuper les citoyens
donc ça commence à donner quelque chose
qui quitte un sujet sensible
l'ensemble des partis d'opposition aussi
sont favorables à la hausse des
redevances donc c'est une belle
stratégie peut-être juste politique
l'apport la cac on le verra l'automne si
le projet de loi a bien lieu ici il y à
une adoption mais également il faut
savoir c'est ça que
c'est très politique également parce
qu'elle à partir du moment où on
connaître eux qui sont les grands prés
leur dos ça mettra probablement à jour
les conflits de l' usage de l'eau et à
ce moment là il faudra faire des choix
donc absolument merci beaucoup madame
pétré on doit s'arrêter là toujours
merci d'avoir été versées bonne soirée
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i cirdi
oh
[Musique]